Okay rogan
experience
paradise.
Why are you right now?
And uh,
I was gonna I was gonna Watch the Bisping
fight the Bisbing Kelvin guests limb
fight live and uh,
do like sort of a breakdown
of it while it was happening.
But the shit was going on at like two
o'clock in the morning out here and
it wasn't happening.
I have been eating like
a pig and drinking.
I've been doing vacation type shit.
I'm a strong believer in that
you need to do vacation time.
Like vacation time is important.
You can't just be working all the time.
Occasionally you have to just fuck off.
And so that's what I've been doing.
I just been fucking off.
So I,
I was tired and I decided I
am not going to stay up late.
And so I watched it in the morning.
I watched it this morning and I've
got a couple of thoughts on it.
First of all,
um,
Brennan Chub said this on his
Instagram and I could not agree more.
I don't think you should be allowed to
fight three weeks after you have a brutal
fight like Michael Bisping did with GSP.
He got rocked,
he got choked unconscious and then
three weeks later he's fighting a really
dangerous,
yeah,
young and up and coming Kelvin
gas alum and Calvin is a beast.
He's gotten nasty boxing and that
is what he showed in that fight.
He hit him with a beautiful straight right
jab and a right hand behind it and oh
my goodness.
It was just,
that kid is just on fire.
He's,
he's just on another level right now.
I'm super,
super impressed with Calvin.
Calvin has got lightening
fast hands and he's,
he's an interesting guy because
he's what I would call a tweener.
And what that means is that I don't,
I mean I think Kelvin
in
in the best,
best of times,
like if Calvin has the best camp
and the the best performance,
it's entirely possible that he
could beat anybody at 185 pounds.
But should he be at 185 pounds?
Boy,
I don't know because Chris
Weidman is that 185 pounds.
And when Chris Weidman
got Calvin to the ground,
it really did look like you're talking
about two completely different weight
classes.
And Chris Weidman was
able to show Calvin out.
And obviously Weidman is a former champion
and there's absolutely no shame in
losing to Chris Weidman,
but it's just the way
it looked when you were
watching the fight.
To me it looked like two
different weight classes.
And,
um,
there's a lot of people that think that
really Calvin should be fighting at 170
pounds if he got the proper diet.
And he was doing that for a while.
Uh,
it was at one point in time,
he was,
uh,
no,
dolce was working with
them for a while and,
uh,
he had his diet in line and
he looked fantastic and then,
you know,
just things happen and he didn't
want to pay the dolce money.
And,
uh,
I dunno who he's working with
right now as a nutritionist,
but I just,
uh,
I think he's a phenomenal fighter.
I just don't know if 185 pounds is,
is the right way class form.
It could be.
I mean,
it could be that maybe what he really
needs to do is just lose some body fat,
put on some muscle and maybe 185
pounds will be his weight class.
It's just that constant debate of whether
or not you should weaken your body and
dropped down to the minimum weight you
can or whether or not you should fight at
a natural way and have a healthy body.
It's,
it's a real good argument.
And I'm pausing right now
because I'm pulling something up.
Uh,
there's a girl that
just died in Australia.
Uh,
she died
very recently.
Uh,
she was preparing for a
Moitai fight and it's just,
it's just part of what
this sport is about.
Unfortunately.
It did really bothers the
fucking shit out of me.
I think it's the scariest thing.
Uh,
I think,
um,
yeah.
Here it is.
Teenager dies training.
Um,
the,
the girl's name,
she was 18 years old and uh,
her name was Jessica Lindsey and she
died while she was cutting weight.
She was an amateur
kickboxer and Australia.
Um,
I cut weight a bunch of times when I
was doing taekwondo tournaments and,
uh,
it is brutal.
It's,
it's terrible.
I was bad at it too.
I didn't do it correctly.
I just worked out real hard the night
before and more rubber suits and the whole
deal and dehydrated myself and I
didn't rehydrate myself well either.
So I felt like shit the next
day when I was fighting.
And,
uh,
a lot of wrestlers back in the
day used to do the same thing.
Um,
my weight cut though was nowhere near as
extreme as some of the MMA fighters do.
Some MMA fighters.
I mean,
they're getting on death's door and,
um,
I just,
I just think it's a,
one of the most disturbing and a
most unfortunate aspects of MMA.
Uh,
Kevin Lee said before his last
fight with Tony Ferguson that,
you know,
he felt like he was,
he was dying when he was cutting weight
and he made the weight Habib number go
Madoff,
who is the,
if not the best,
one of the very best
lightweights in the world.
Um,
undefeated
had his body shut down last time.
He tried to make the weight and
couldn't make the Tony Ferguson fight.
They pulled him out and
took him to the hospital.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm beating a dead horse here cause
it's something that everybody knows.
Everybody's aware that it's a terrible,
terrible aspect of our sport.
And in my mind it's contrary to what
martial arts is supposed to be about.
So in that sense,
I encourage Kelvin to stay at 185 pounds
because obviously the guy's knocked out
Vidor Belford at one 85 he just
knocked out a former champion,
Michael Bisbing at 185 pounds.
I mean,
he could knock on anybody at one 85 but
a guy like Chris Weidman who is very
smart about cutting weight,
he cuts a lot of weight,
but he does it the right way.
Rehydrates the right way and
he's just a fucking beast.
He's just so much bigger.
And when he got Kelvin to the ground and
submitted him with a head and arm choke
boy,
it just really seemed like that's
the wrong way class for Calvin.
And then you see Calvin next fight,
fight Bisbing and just fucking
lights him up in the first round.
Now would he have been able to do
that if he fought the Bisbing that was
training for George Saint Pierre.
I mean,
if Bisping did not have the George Saint
Pierre fight and it just went right
into the Calvin Gasland fight
with the same result of happen,
it could very well have
the way Calvin hits,
he's fast as fuck.
His hands are beautiful.
He throws really crisp straight punches.
And in this sport it's,
there's not a whole lot
of guys who have crisper,
sharper hands at 185 pounds.
Then Calvin,
I mean,
he just has beautiful head movement and
boxing and when he moves in for the kill
with those hands,
whoa.
When you saw the Vito Belfort fight,
I mean he just fucking be tore up,
but those straight punches and he throws
them efficiently and they have snapped
to them.
And just,
and on top of that,
he's a very good wrestler.
I mean,
a lot of people forget how good his
wrestling skills are on top of all that.
He's just a real threat at 185 pounds.
Fascinating thing because it's
just such a wide open division.
He just called out,
um,
Robert Whitaker,
who was the interim champion of course,
and a call that Whittaker
and wants Whitaker to,
uh,
to fight him next.
But of course,
Robert Whitaker is a
waiting for the big pay day.
I would too if I was him
to fight George St Pierre.
So it's a,
it's a wide open division now
that Saint Pierre choked out.
Michael Bisbing and then
Gelt Kelvin just lights up.
Bisping.
And of course,
you've got to think that
Weidman is still in the mix.
I mean,
even though why been lost to Yoel Romero.
And then last two gig garden was saucy.
He's still in the mix.
Uh,
he was winning that Yoel Romero fight,
in my opinion until he got caught,
was that wicked flying knee.
But that's the danger
of fighting Gol Romero,
you all Romero could do that
to anybody in the world.
He's just such a fucking freak athlete.
Uh,
so really,
really wide open division.
I'm bombed as fuck that
gay guard went over.
And,
uh,
decided to,
fight for bell tour,
but I get it,
you know,
I mean these guys got to go where the
money is and at Pella tour he easily could
be a champion.
I think he could be a
champion in the UFC as well.
And maybe we will see
him in the UFC again.
I mean,
he could easily find a year or two over
in the UFC and then come back over.
K guard is still relatively young,
but it's nice to have competition.
I think competition is good
for everybody and I think it,
uh,
I think it really elevates the sport.
It elevates the level of sport.
I end it,
you could see by the results that a
lot of these UFC fighters are having.
Um,
especially Lorens Larkin who is very good,
he's a very,
very good striker.
He loses to Lima in a bid for
the title and then loses by,
knock out to the always
dangerous pol daily.
So I think Bella tore it.
And now,
especially in that 170 pound division,
you've got Rory McDonald bell tours
really showing they have absolute world
championship caliber,
caliber talent over there.
So to get back to that fight,
uh,
I agree entirely with a,
to get back to the Bisbing and,
uh,
Calvin Gasol and fight,
I agree 100% with what
Brendan Schaub said,
that you really have to protect
a fighter from themselves.
You really can't be letting a guy fight
three weeks after an absolutely brutal
fight like that.
It just does not make sense.
Um,
I don't think it's smart.
I mean,
I understand that UFC needed someone
to fill in and short notice because
Anderson Silva tested positive
for performance enhancing
drugs and they did not
want to lose the,
uh,
Shanghai main event.
So it turns into an even bigger fight
when you've got the former middleweight
champion right off of his last
three weeks later fighting again.
But
it's just not smart.
I know Bisping wanted to do it.
I know Bisping would probably
do it again if you asked to do,
if you,
if you ask Bisbing to fight in
a couple of weeks of probably,
probably do it again.
And,
and,
um,
someone was talking about
him fighting in England,
I believe in March,
which
boy,
I mean,
that's less crazy,
but still crazy,
right?
Because,
uh,
we're basically an into December.
So you got December,
January,
February,
three months off really,
and then march.
But of course during that time he's
going to be sparring and you know,
you know,
Bisping,
he's a fucking animal.
He's not going to train easy.
He's not gonna take much time off.
And,
uh,
there's a lot of debate as to how much
time a fighter should be forced to take
off after they get knocked out.
And here's the thing about that.
You're,
you're seeing guys
when they're fighting and you're seeing
them getting knocked down and you're
seeing them fighting,
you know,
x amount of months later.
So you saw Bisping,
he didn't get knocked out
by George Saint Pierre,
but he's certainly got
rocked with that left hook.
And then,
uh,
he got choked out when
he was on the ground.
I now,
for people who don't know a lot about MMA,
getting choked out is not nearly
as bad as getting knocked out.
It's,
there's almost nothing to it.
The way to look at it is if you look at
a garden hose and you know how to give
Ben the garden hose,
crimp it down and it stops
the water from coming out.
That's exactly what happens to your
fucking brain when you get choked out.
When you get choked out,
it's basically cutting off the blood.
Your brain,
you wake up and you're fine.
You don't have memory issues,
you don't have balance
issues for the most part,
especially if you've only been
out for a couple of seconds.
Um,
it happens all of the time in training.
Uh,
I've seen many,
many guys get choked unconscious.
I've choked people unconscious.
They come back and they're fine.
It's not that big of a deal,
but you got to realize before
he got choked unconscious,
he got hit with a big
fucking lefthand and hurt.
And it was a great fight before that.
Uh,
both guys were were giving and tanking
fighters need time off after fights.
So you're seeing that,
right?
You're seeing the actual competition
between George Saint Pierre,
Michael Bisping.
What were you not seeing is how many
times he got hit during training?
Did he get rocked ever?
Did he get clipped and dropped a,
did he get dropped and heard and take a
couple of days off and then get back to
training again?
Only he knows.
Only his camp knows and most of
the times they're not talking.
But you hear about it all the time.
And matter of fact,
I was talking to Forrest Griffin wants,
and Forrest was telling me that
before he fought Anderson Silva,
he was knocked unconscious
twice in training.
That's fucking crazy.
I mean,
here he is
about to fight the greatest pound
for pound fighter of all time.
Next to,
I mean if there's,
there's,
there's three guys in that debate,
right?
My,
my number one guy right
now is mighty mouse.
I think just he,
he represents the highest skill level.
But does he represent the
highest competition level
in terms of like the guys
he's faced?
I don't think so.
I think number one competition
level is Jon Jones.
Jon Jones has choked out
Liotta Machida rampage Jackson.
He's beat Rashad Evans.
He beat Alexander Gustafson,
he'd beat Glover to sharer.
He beat Vitor Belfort.
He beat Daniel Cormier twice.
I mean fuck,
he's beating everybody.
I think you look at competition wise,
Jon Jones is a very strong argument
for the greatest of all time,
but Anderson Silva's
fucking bright there too,
man.
Anderson Silva in his prime.
I think when you look at
the way he knocked out,
Vitor Belfort with that
front kick to the face,
when you look at the way he fought,
Forrest Griffin in,
in that fight that we
were just talking about,
and k owed him like a magician the way
he fought Stephan Bonner and literally
put his back up against the cage.
They again,
Stephan Bonner and
Forrest Griffin to just,
no disrespect,
they're not at the same level as a Leo
Machida or Glover to sharer or some of
the guys that Jon Jones has faced,
but it's the way Anderson beat them.
I mean,
Anderson was just in his prime.
He was off fucking master,
like a real master.
Uh,
so Forrest Griffin fighting Anderson
Silva after being Kao twice in training
camp is just insane.
But these are the things that
fighters do when they have to do them.
You know,
you're talking about a giant pay day,
you're talking about a big fight.
You give the guy a chance like,
do you want to fight?
Do you think you could fight?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
I could do it.
And they go out there and
they're compromised and
they get clipped and you see
it immediately.
Sometimes.
Sometimes you see guys,
they get clipped and you
don't know what I mean.
They get hit with something
and look at any day,
any time when a person is throwing a
punch or kick at you and it connects,
it can put you out.
But there's no doubt at all,
no doubt about it,
that the resiliency of a fighter
after they'd been KOD is compromised.
There's just no doubt about it.
When you see a guy who's been KOD
and then you see them get hit weeks,
months later,
they cannot take a shot at the same way.
Their brain is still recovering,
their body is still recovering
from the concussion.
And uh,
you have to figure out a way to balance
being a risk taker and seizing an
opportunity,
which is a huge opportunity versus
concentrating on having a long and healthy
career.
Now that said,
for Michael Bisping,
he's kind of at the end of his career.
I mean,
he said essentially that he wants
to fight one more time in England,
which would be beautiful for
him and I hope they give him,
uh,
you know,
a good matchup.
So it'd be a good fight for the fans.
And I hope they give
Michael some time off.
You know,
give the man some time to really relax
and then go through a real nice three,
four month training camp,
get an excellent shape and give
his best effort for one more.
Go at it.
I would like to see that,
but it might be the hardest shit in the
world to talk a fighter into retiring or
to for a fighter to
figure out when to retire.
I was just talking to Matt Brown.
Um,
he came to see me in Denver
and I was telling him,
I was like,
dude,
that fight that you
have with Diego Sanchez,
what a perfect way to go out.
Beautiful,
spectacular knockouts,
Classic Matt Brown fight.
Just blood and guts.
He's one of my all time favorite fighters
to watch for sure because he's so
fucking for Roche's.
You knew when you were going to
go to see a matte brown fight.
If Matt Brown was fighting,
anybody win,
lose or draw,
that guy was going to have to face hell.
Matt Brown would bring it in.
The four Rosti intensity that that guy
would bring inside the octagon is just
unrivaled.
And I think about Matt is,
he's,
he's not like an unbelievably
physically gifted guy.
He's not like some Kevin
Randleman character.
You know,
there's been guys that
are just physical freaks.
You know,
Anthony Rumble Johnson,
there's a,
you know Brock Lesnar,
there's,
there's guys that are just physically,
they're just freakish.
They can do things that are
just incredibly unusual.
And then there's guys that
their mind is just unbreakable.
They're just off fucking warrior
to the core down to the cells.
That's Matt Brown and Matt Brown can lose.
He's lost before,
but he just loses because
his body gives out.
It's never because his mind gives out.
I mean that guy is coming to fucking
kill you every time he gets into that
octagon.
And I loved that about him.
I mean it's one of my all time
favorite fighters to watch for sure.
And when I was telling
him a congratulations,
I mean it's an amazing
way to cap off a career.
He's like,
might not be the last one.
So he's still,
you know,
even after going through all those wars,
he's in his thirties now,
I believe he's like 35 I think
he is maybe 36 and you know,
still wondering.
I think he's 36 it's still wondering like
is this it to go one more do one more,
one more.
Cause the thrill that you experience.
I mean obviously I've never fought
inside the octagon so I'm just guessing.
But the thrill of just
fighting in general,
it's such a much higher level of
danger and excitement than most people
experience in everyday life and it's
incredibly addictive and it makes regular
life seem dull and gray in comparison.
When those guys get into the octagon,
when a guy like Matt Brown smashes an
elbow down on Diego Sanchez and Diego
slumps and goes limp and
the crowd goes insane.
And you know when just when
Matt got into the octagon,
there's a crazy video of the fight
while we're watching the fight,
Matt steps into the octagon steps
through the cage and fucking roars.
I mean raw bars,
like you see it in his face,
you see it in his eyes.
He just opens his mouth and screams
that mother fucker was there to fight.
That's what he loves to do.
And it was finally there.
It was finally happening.
It gets to the training camp
steps into that octagon.
It's go time.
That is is exciting as life
is going to be for him or for,
for any combat sports athlete.
And it is incredibly,
incredibly hard to give that up.
Once you've experienced that man,
I mean,
you see it in these guys.
It's so hard for them to
know when to walk away,
but I think it's incredibly critical to
balance out the glory of Combat Sports,
the glory of giving your all and
going out on your shield sometimes and
sometimes winning with vicious
knockout or incredible submission,
but knowing when the
body has taken enough,
knowing when your vehicle is damaged
to the point where you should not be
engaging in competition anymore.
And it's different for everybody
and it's so hard to figure out when,
and some guys just know,
some guys just know and they'll go,
you know what?
I'm good.
It's it,
uh,
I don't feel it anymore.
I'm going to step away.
Um,
Tj grants a good example of that.
Here's a guy that was supposed
to be fighting for the title.
He's about to fight for the
UFC lightweight title and
nobody ever heard from him
again.
He was suffering from concussion syndrome.
He just had real hard time recovering
from a concussion that he gotten training
and uh,
never fought again.
Took a regular job,
but he's done some training,
training fighters and stuff,
but never decided to get
back into the octagon again.
Chris Holdsworth and other
example got a training injury,
get hit in the head and training real bad,
got a concussion and um,
decided to stop.
And that was it.
Very hard for these
guys to figure out when.
So,
um,
next Saturday,
December 2nd,
there's a big fight.
It's the rematch between
Max Holloway and Josie Aldo.
You also have Alistair Overeem
and Francis in Ghana on that card.
Whoa.
Henry said Udo and Sergio Pettis,
Eddie Alvarez,
and just engaging who?
Just those four fights,
right?
Their whole Lee Shit.
Holy Shit.
I know a,
I talked about Holloway
versus all though before.
Um,
what I like about this
fight is first of all,
the first fight was very good until,
although,
um,
ran out of gas and Holloway took over.
Um,
all those camp was saying that going
into that fight all though had a leg
injury,
which kind of makes sense because you
really didn't throw many leg kicks,
but he also didn't throw very many
leg kicks against Frankie Edgar.
I think the strategy for then for that
fight though was that he was worried
about the takedowns of Frankie Edgar.
So he had decided to
avoid being taken down.
One of the best ways to do it would be
just to avoid kicking and just outbox
him.
And he did that very well in that
fight and won a pretty clear unanimous
decision.
This is going to be a different fighter.
I mean Max Holloway is in his prime.
He beat,
although the first time around isn't he?
And he's incredibly confident there's
going to be able to beat all the second
time.
All go though said that he had this
leg injury and it prevented him from
throwing leg kicks but
that it's better now.
And that's one of the reasons why he's
excited about fighting Holloway again.
Now if that is the case and if
all though is in tremendous shape,
cause he took this fight
on relatively short notice,
he did not get a full two,
three month training camp.
I think it was five weeks out,
maybe more.
I'm sorry if I'm wrong about that.
I'm not looking at it right in front
of me but I know it wasn't a full camp
cause I know it was supposed to be
Frankie Edgar Edgar got injured and so all
those steps in,
so we're gonna find out,
we're going to find out if Aldo can make
the proper adjustments and whether or
not the ability to throw leg kicks is
going to make a difference because all
those leg kicks classically in history
have been some of the very best in the
game.
If you look at his fight with Uriah Faber,
it's one of the very best uses,
uses best use of leg kicks maybe
in the featherweight division ever.
And just smash Uriah Faber,
his leg to the point where,
I mean it's one of the all time grossest
and injuries and MMA you rise left leg
was like twice the size of his right leg
and had to do a bunch of crazy therapy
to recover from him hyperbaric chamber.
And you know,
he documented it.
Your eyes.
He's such a cool dude.
He's uh,
I loved that he did this.
He,
he documented a lot of the injury
online to show everybody like,
look how fucked up my leg is.
And uh,
that's all done at its best
is although the same guy now,
I mean he's gone through 29 professional
MMA fights at the highest level.
He's been a champion for
a long time and you know,
he's had some wars.
The second fight with
Chad Mendez was a war.
Of course he got stopped
quick by Conor Mcgregor.
The fight with Max Holloway was a war.
I mean,
he's been through some,
some really tough fights.
Does he still have that same level?
You know,
we really don't know.
And we're going to find out,
hopefully we're going to
find out from a an inch.
I mean,
I don't know what kind of
camp he was involved in,
like how hard he was training rather
before he entered into camp for this
championship fight.
I'm hoping that he was in good shape and
that's one of the reasons why he was so
eager to take the fight.
And we're gonna find out we're
going to fly out on Saturday night.
And that's very interesting.
But maybe even more interesting is
Alistair Overeem and Francis in Ghana,
because Alistair are over.
Overeem was one of the most
experienced guys in the division.
Of course,
Overeem is the former
dream heavyweight champion,
former Strikeforce heavyweight champion
and former k one grand Prix champion.
One of the very best kick boxers to
ever fight in MMA without a doubt.
But you want to talk about a guy who has
been in wars like let's Google Allister
overall record because it's
gotta be fucking crazy.
As far as the number of
times he's been stopped.
I mean,
it's really fucking bananas.
Let's go and look.
We'll first look at his MMA career.
We'll count this up and this
is no disrespect to him.
I'm a huge Alistair Overeem fan and
I'm not saying that he should retire or
anything crazy like that,
but let's just take a look at
how many times he's been stopped.
Just an MMA.
Okay.
So he won two fights in a row,
a fantastic victory over Mark Hunt.
It Kod him with knees and one a split
decision over for breezy over doom.
Um,
or actually a majority decision.
One,
one of the referees,
I guess call or one of the
judges called it a draw.
I thought that was a very close decision,
but I thought that [inaudible]
was going to get the nod.
Quite honestly.
Let's look at the,
the times he's lost though.
Steep.
Amy.
Oh,
chip.
When he fought for the title,
knocked him out.
Okay.
Before that,
Ben Rothwell knocked him out before that
Travis Browne knocked him out before
that Antonio big foot
Silva knocked him out.
Brutal knockout.
So that's just within the
last four years in the UFC.
He suffered for brutal knockouts
before that surrogate Keratan off,
knocked him out.
Brutal knockout in 2007,
10 years ago,
Mauricio Shogun Hua knocked them out.
Also in 2007,
uh,
he lost to Ricardo Arona.
He got stopped in that fight.
He tapped two strikes,
a Ho Geria Nogueira uh,
stopped him.
Little Nog stopped him.
Uh,
his corner stopped it by,
it's a Tko.
That was in 2006.
He got stopped by Fabrizio over doom,
but that was a Komora and
that was a submission.
Um,
Shogun who,
uh,
stopped him,
the first time in 2005 so
shogun knocked him out twice.
He TKO them in 2005 and Kayo them in
2007 before that little Nog beat him by
decision chocolate dealt k owed him
and a fantastic fight where overin was
really coming on strong against chuck.
And then,
uh,
chuck caught him with some
brutal punches and killed him.
That was in 2003 before that,
Bobby Hoffman,
a lot of people forgot about
Bobby Hoffman way back and rings.
Um,
Kay owed him in 2000
and that's it for MMA.
So just MMA chaos,
right?
The first Kale loss.
We have Bobby Hoffman
than we have chocolate,
Dell.
Then we have shogun,
then we have a little Nog,
then we have a Rona,
then we have shogun again.
Then we have Keratan off.
Okay.
We already have seven that's Keratan off.
Then we have big foot Silva,
eight Travis Browne,
nine Ben Rothwell,
10 steep Emile Chick,
1111 stoppage losses in MMA.
I mean,
holy fucking shit.
That's crazy.
11 knockout or stoppage losses in MMA.
Then you'd go to kickboxing.
Badr.
Hari stopped him in the k
one Grand Prix final in 2009.
He stopped him.
Um,
he got stopped by Glob a Tosa in,
um,
kill Kachin versus k one 2004,
he got Kod.
He got stopped by Bernard
Paris and k one Holland.
That's in 2001,
so one,
two,
three k o losses and kickboxing on
top of all the other MMA losses.
So that's a lot of fucking
stoppage losses folks.
And it's led people to question
the durability of the current guy.
But what we do know is that Allister is
extremely crafty and one of the things
that I like about Allister these days
as since he's gone over to Jackson
Winkeljohn in Albuquerque,
he has become much more elusive,
um,
much slicker on his feet,
moves around a lot more and
doesn't just try to smash people.
The Uber Ream,
the guy that we saw fight
Brock Lesnar when the,
in his UFC debut that
was like classic Uber,
which is Jack to the tits smash and people
running through people he would meet
force with greater force.
Now what you're seeing is we're seeing
as the ouster over him the fuck junior
dos Santos who farted,
incredibly clever fight,
moved around.
Well,
um,
he was very,
very slick,
very difficult to hit and then started
scoring on junior and then eventually
caught him with a beautiful
left hook and Kale at him.
That's that to me is the interesting
Andre Arlovski as tea today.
A guy who realizes that perhaps you can't
take a punch like you did when he was
younger.
You know,
he's been in a lot of really,
really tough fights as we
just went over and realized,
it's like,
hey,
now I have to be smart.
Now I have to be clever.
I have to move around a lot
and I have to use my skills.
And his skills are substantial.
In my opinion.
He's the best,
I mean,
right up there with mark on of course,
um,
who he just beat the best heavyweight
kickboxer every money it comes to
credentials.
He's the best.
Kevin heavyweight kickboxer ever in MMA.
Really a no,
no heavyweight kickboxer other
than him and hunt have everyone,
the k one Grand Prix and hunt one it,
he stepped into the
finals as an alternate.
He had lost earlier that night.
Uh,
not to take anything away
from hunt because of course,
Mark Honda is still just one of the all
time greats when it comes to kickboxing.
But when Mark Hunt One,
um,
he one,
we can go to that record right here,
Mark Hunt One,
um,
the k one grand Prix he wanted,
he had lost that night.
Um,
see,
he's,
he's fought the Caitlin
Grand Prix a couple of times.
He lost a semi shelt uh,
he got a Tki owed by a
spinning back kick and he won.
Um,
why don't I say God damn,
he's fought a lot of fucking
awesome kickboxing fights too.
So he lost to race CFO in
2001 and the semifinals.
And then he won that night.
He beat Stefan Leco.
Yeah.
So he lost to Ray Sefo.
Ray Sefo apparently couldn't continue
and then he came back to win from getting
that right.
Yeah.
It looks like he beat Stefan Leco
in the,
uh,
75 watts has semifinals says winds,
k one Grand Prix championship 2001.
Oh,
okay.
He fought Francisco Filio but that was in,
I'm looking at a different date.
That was in,
uh,
2002 or 2001 he'd be feeling,
anyway,
I'm rambling.
Did you notice?
Yeah,
I'm talking too much.
Um,
but,
so he's fighting Frances,
Frances and Ghana and Francis and Ghana
who is right now 10 and one of the UFC
10,
uh,
ten one with a zero draws.
So 10 wins and it's just
been smashing everybody.
And if he looked at his last
fight against Andre Arlovski,
that was a fight where it's like
probably one of the first fights where we
really got tested.
We really got to see what happens
when he fights a former champion,
a former really world class fighter and a,
it was a good test,
but now a bigger test is in front
of them when he's going to fight.
Alistair Overeem,
I mean we've seen him so far,
four times inside the octagon.
Uh,
he stopped Curtis blades by knockout.
He stopped bull hon.
I don't know how to say
this guy's name again.
Me.
I owe Vich me how you've,
I don't remember how to get bullion.
Mihailo Vich I do remember
how to say homeboy's name.
Um,
then he stopped Anthony Hamilton,
uh,
by submission showing that he
has submission skills as well.
And then of course just knocked out
Andre Arlovski in his last fight.
It's a very interesting fight because the,
the question is,
is in Ghana ready for a guy who's
got the skills of Alistair over him?
The skill,
the experience at the highest level,
the craftiness,
is he going to set traps and is Frances
and gone going to be fall for those
traps?
The other question is,
can all can Alster Overeem take a shot
from in Ghana and Ghana has legitimate
absolute one punch knockout power,
extreme confidence and he's fresh and
in his prime right now actually entering
his prime,
I mean arguably he hasn't even reached
its prime yet because in Ghana was one of
those guys that had 31 years of
age is near his physical prime,
but it's still learning.
He's still getting better at the sport
and as he fights better and better
competition,
you're going to see more of a skill shine.
You're going to see where the holes are
in his game and you're going to see how
he responds to adversity.
Hopefully we're going to get a chance
to see all those things in his fight.
Um,
if Overeem wins,
there's a very good argument for
him being next in line to fights.
Deep Abo chip.
The real question about
the heavyweight division,
the real question other than,
um,
you know,
who's next for Steve Bay?
The real question is the
health of Cain Velasquez.
Cain Velasquez,
in my opinion,
is without a doubt one of the
greatest heavyweights of all time.
Um,
he's just a force of
nature when he's in shape.
When you,
when you see the Cain Velasquez
that beat Ben Rothwell,
when you see that Cain Velasquez
that just stormed the division,
when you see him in the second and
third fight with junior dos Santos,
that Cain Velasquez is a fucking monster.
The question is,
after all the surgeries,
back surgery,
knee surgery,
shoulder surgery,
can he come back and be that guy again?
Um,
as a fan,
I most certainly hope we can,
but we're really not going to know.
Um,
another fight in the car that's
very interesting is Henry.
So Hutto and Sergio Pettis.
Sergio Pettis is the
younger brother of showtime,
Pettis,
Anthony Pettis,
who was the former lightweight
champion and Henry.
So Hutto of course is a
former Olympic gold medalist,
the number two ranked
fly weight in the world.
And Henry is coming off of an absolutely
spectacular Kao of Wilson Hayes.
I was blown away by him in
that fight and that fight,
he looked like some
sort of a karate master.
I mean that was a,
it was a very,
very interesting fight.
Before that he lost a Benevidez and
benefit is of course one of the most
experienced,
one of the best guys in the
division and he lost it very,
very close fight.
A fight where I've talked to his coaches
afterwards and they were really pissed
off by the decision they thought
so Hutto could have gotten the nod,
but he rebounded and he rebounded
versus Wilson Hayes and looked like a
completely different fighter.
The thing that excites
me about this fight,
it's two things.
One,
the potential of Sergio Pettis.
Sergio Pettis is a young kid.
He's one of the youngest
guys in the division.
He's the extremely talented younger
brother of another extremely talented
fighter.
So he's had martial arts in his life.
You know,
most of the time growing up,
he's 24 years old now.
He trains under the Great Duke Roufus
who in my opinion is one of the very best
guys in the division in terms of
his ability to coach fighters.
He's fucking fantastic.
Doof not to division.
I mean,
I should say in,
in,
in the sport.
Uh,
Duke Roufus has just an
amazing striking coach.
He's a former world Moy
Thai champion himself,
outstanding kickboxer and
extremely knowledgeable
about both kickboxing and MMA
and one of the best guys in the
world at training kickboxers for MMA.
I mean,
he's just fantastic.
And what we've seen from young Sergio,
we saw him get,
um,
submitted by Alex,
get Sarah's early on in
his career and Alex is,
uh,
just slicker and caught him on the ground.
And uh,
and then we saw him lose
again to Ryan Benoit.
I think that these losses,
especially for a young fighter,
are absolutely critical.
I think you find out what you're really
made of you and you see what you need to
improve upon.
And in fighting tough guys early on,
like Alex Caceres,
like Ryan Benoit,
I mean,
and we're talking about two
years ago he fought Benoit.
He was 21 years old then,
so or 22 years old,
he's 24 now.
So He's a really young kid,
still learning,
still growing on the job and uh,
has looked fantastic.
And his last few fights looked really
good against John Moraga and looked even
better against Brandon
Marino in his last fight,
which was a five round,
unanimous decision victory.
So this is my opinion,
is going to be the toughest fight
of his career because Henry,
so Hutto just has that Olympic
gold medal winner mindset,
the mindset of a galaxy Hutto I mean this
guy is focused on being a champion 24
hours a day.
And if you look at the way he
fought against Wilson Hayes,
I mean if,
if that's indicative of the kind of
improvement that this guy can make and
carrying Gibbons who,
um,
is,
uh,
another fucking phenomenal
Muay Thai coach,
he told me that this kid is just a
sponge and just can learn so fast that a
ridiculous way.
And I think you looking at
athletic prowess in Henry pseudo,
but I think maybe perhaps
more important than that,
you're looking at his mind.
His mind is just ultra sharp and focused
and determined and he's just got that
championship mindset.
I mean that's why he is an Olympic
gold medalist and a wrestling.
So he's got unparalleled
wrestling skill in the division.
And then on top of that,
if you look at the Wilson Hayes fight,
you look at radical improvements
in his striking and movement.
I mean he looked like a combination of
a Prime Leo Machida and Conor Mcgregor
versus with his movement
against Wilson Hayes.
I think a lot of guys are
realizing that karate style,
if you have all those other bases covered,
if you have great wrestling,
if you have submissions,
good takedown defense and good
boxing skills as well as moy,
Tai,
everything else,
that karate stance,
that sideways stance that we see employed
all the time by Wonderboy Thompson
that we see.
Um,
um,
we've seen a,
a bunch of different fighters.
Of course,
Leo Machida,
a bunch of different fighters use
that stance inside the octagon.
Conor McGregor,
it's a very difficult stance to deal with.
It's a,
if you're good at it and if
you're good at that movement,
that in and out side to side movement,
uh,
Michael Venom page has a
very unusual take on that,
uh,
fighting and Bella tore.
He likes to fight like that too.
And of course he's a former
point fighting champion.
That style is fucking hard to deal with.
It's really hard for guys to judge
and if you're dealing with a guy like,
so Huda whose lightning fast on top of
that and starts moving like that with
those worldclass wrestling
skills with excellent striking,
um,
you know,
classic striking boxing and kickboxing,
very difficult to deal with.
I'm very interested to
see what style he takes a,
or how he approaches this
fight with Sergio Pettis.
He's quite a bit older
than Sergio being 30.
Um,
that's a really interesting fight.
I'm very curious.
I,
I just do not know how that
one's going to play out.
One fight that I don't know how to,
it's going to play out,
but I'm fucking beyond pumped for it is
Eddie Alvarez and just engage you just
engage.
He is a fucking savage
and so's Eddie Alvarez.
Eddie Alvarez is a beast and I think a
lot of people are looking past Alvarez.
Alvarez had just come off of
that brutal knockout loss,
uh,
kind of a humiliating knockout
loss to Conor McGregor.
And then after that he is involved in the,
the no contest,
uh,
versus um,
Dustin poor yet.
I believe that was an eye poke.
Um,
that is,
I'm trying to remember
how that fight went down,
but I do not,
I feel like someone got poked in the eye.
Uh,
either way it's a no contest.
So that obviously doesn't move him up
the ladder any and he's got to regroup.
Yeah,
no contest.
Here it is.
Yeah.
This was a,
okay,
now I remember what it was.
It wasn't an eye poke.
It was a knee to a downed opponent and
it was a fucking phenomenal fight while
it played out against Dustin Poirier.
Yay.
They were going back and forth.
Now,
I remember the fight and poor ea had
Alverez in some deep trouble and Alvarez
rebounded.
And Alvarez I believe,
hit Dustin employee Aa with
a knee while he was down.
Yeah,
that's exactly what happened.
And interesting.
Yeah.
See,
this is what happened.
Pour.
Yay.
Um,
Alvarez,
you know,
Herb Dean was Safat defending it,
saying that Alvarez didn't
intentionally need pour.
Yay.
And if I remember,
the fight is a crazy war.
Uh,
Alvarez had been rocked.
[inaudible] had been,
Brock poet was bloodied and um,
Alvarez hit him with
an unintentional knee,
um,
that could have resulted in a
disqualification when for poor.
Yay.
And Paula was saying that
he looked at it as a win,
which is,
uh,
interesting.
Um,
so anyway,
pull a rebounded from
that fight obviously,
and uh,
stopped Anthony Pettis in his last fight
so that the division is just crazy in
me.
Unbelievably hot right now.
Um,
and everybody waiting to see what
the fuck happens with Conor McGregor
rebounding.
But Eddie Alvarez with a no contest.
And before that,
the Kale lost econom McGregor
desperately needs a win.
And he's coming in there against one
of the most fucking savage guys in the
division.
Just engaging,
showed in that Michael Johnson fight what
he's made of and a lot of people were
very excited to see
him inside the octagon.
He had been fighting in the world
series of fighting and looking like an
absolute monster,
but against what a lot of people
thought was just not the same caliber of
competition as the UFC offered.
And so they wanted to see what would
happen if he fought a real world class
fighter.
And what we saw in the
Michael Johnson fight,
it's adjusting gauge.
He who fights,
uh,
I don't want to say reckless,
but he puts himself in danger and it's
one of the things that makes him so
exciting.
He forces his will on people.
He's a ferocious striker and a,
an excellent wrestlers as well,
and just fucking puts it on fighters.
He tests there will,
he puts tremendous pressure on fighters.
And the,
the fight with Michael Johnson
was just a pleasure to watch,
just so much fun and so fucking crazy.
There was so much chaos in that fight.
And a lot of people were introduced
to just engage you from that fight.
The hardcore fans had known him already
from the world series of fighting and
had heard about him through the Internet.
But the UFC fans and uh,
the people that were watching that night,
they really got a chance
to be treated too.
Does the kind of chaotic fight that
is really going to bring like a of the
casual fan when they see a
guy like just engaging fight.
It's really gonna make
you a fan of this kid.
Just his style is just,
there's very few guys,
I mean other than,
I mean Matt Brown who
I talked about before,
but even Matt Brown is capable of
winning so many different ways.
Whereas Gagey he's gonna probably
try to knock you out or get,
I mean,
he's even said himself that
he might get knocked out.
You're probably going to
see me get knocked out.
He said,
uh,
over the next few years
he's got that mindset,
this kill or be killed mindset.
And,
uh,
it's just absolutely fascinating to
see this kid compete inside the octagon
because he's so fucking crazy because
he's such a fucking animal inside the
octagon.
He just got this,
uh,
undeniable killer instinct
and indomitable spirit.
And there's levels to this game.
There's levels physically,
and he's at a very high level physically,
but there's also levels mentally.
And that's what excites
me about Justice Gagey is,
is the,
the mental level.
He just has zero quit in
him and he's 100% ferocious.
So him fighting a fucking
animal like Eddie Alvarez,
that's just a recipe for a good time.
And we're going to get to see that and
we're going to get to see that next
Saturday night live on paper view.
Woo.
So how long have you been doing
this here for nine minutes.
Black and fucking talk a lot.
Huh?
So,
uh,
also on the undercard,
here's another five.
That's a big fight.
Um,
this is,
uh,
Charles all Avera verses Paul Felder.
Paul Felder continues to impress.
I'll tell you what,
Paul Felder's a fucking phenomenal,
uh,
commentary guy too.
He did commentary guy,
color commentator.
He did a fantastic job doing commentary
for Dana White's Tuesday night fight
show and as [inaudible]
Tuesday night contenders show.
And uh,
he's done some a UFC events now as well.
And just excellent,
great enthusiasm,
very knowledgeable,
great talker,
smart,
articulate guy.
And he's fighting Charles
all of Vera Saturday night.
Now,
Charles all Avera is a guy who has had
mixed success inside the octagon and his
best.
He's been incredible and he shows a great
range of very technical striking and
very,
very solid Brazilian Jujitsu,
but he's had some tough losses.
The,
the Kale lost a cub.
Swanson,
um,
is he burst onto the scene with a,
an amazing victory,
um,
way,
way back in the day.
See,
this is not even Efrain.
Escudero was his second fight
inside of the octagon actually,
and he got him by
standing rear naked choke.
That was a big fight because
Efrain Escudero had won
the ultimate fighter and it
was just,
it was a big victory for him.
And he went down,
he lost to cowboy Serone.
Um,
he got a coyote and the first round he,
uh,
lost to Jim Miller.
He got submitted.
And then the cub Swanson Kao,
he got beat up by Frankie
Edgar in a very fun fight.
Three Round New Anna
you unanimous decision.
Then a Max Holloway put it on him
and stopped him in the first round.
Then Anthony Pettis submitted him.
So he's had some,
some ups and downs.
Ricardo Lamas,
Kod,
em,
uh,
excuse me.
Ricardo Lamas finished in by
submission in the second round,
so he beat,
we'll Brooks by submission in the first
round of his last fight and got back on
track.
Looked excellent in that
fight and fought that fight.
You know,
it was like,
it was a real do or die
fight for him against,
we'll Brooks a guy who was
coming over from Bella tour,
a guy who was very talented and a
Oliveira wound up submitting him.
There was a big victory
for him and in my opinion,
this is one of the most dangerous fights
for him right now at this stage of his
career.
Because Paul Felder is a fucking killer.
He's an animal.
He's very,
very strong physically.
He's a big 155 pound doors.
All.
Avera is a smaller 155 pounder.
I guy was fought at one 45 before,
but just really had a hard
time making that weight.
Um,
fell.
Just going to have a power and strength
advantage and all Avera is going to have
to be crafty and in my opinion,
his best way to win this fight is
to get this fight to the ground.
And that's going to be a tall order,
a very tall order.
Um,
Felder's just a very aggressive,
very durable and extremely
aggressive guy and 155 pounds.
Can I say aggressive one more time.
Um,
I really loved his fight against,
um,
well he's got,
had some amazing fights
inside the octagon,
but what would I liked?
I liked his fights against,
I like his fight against Barboza because
the Barboza fight showed him against
one of the very best strikers in the
division and he'd got out struck.
He lost that fight,
but he was in it every second of the fight
and he was trying to win up until the
very end.
Um,
he's had some ups and
downs inside the octagon,
but he's won two in a row,
both by knock out both
in the first round and,
um,
the Barboza fight and the Ross Pearson
fight or to decision losses that he got a
split decision against Ross Pearson.
He beat Danny Castillo and a spectacular
spinning back fist knock out,
um,
Jason's saga before that.
I mean,
and the Barboza fight I think was just
a good example of like where this guy's
hard is that fought against one of the
best and fastest strikers in the division
and was in it to the end.
It was a real learning experience for
him and that was a also fight of the
night.
So I think Felder at this stage of his
career is really coming into his own.
I don't think he's in his prime yet.
I think,
uh,
at 33 years of age,
we're starting to see
the very best of him.
And he's,
he's got an incredibly bright future,
but also you gotta realize
that 33 years of age,
she kind of got to get after it.
Right now.
I mean this is the time for him and,
uh,
for Olivera Oliver has got to capitalize
on that victory that he just had over.
We'll Brooks and you know,
he's a little bit younger at 28 and
still got massive potential and an
incredible amount of experience
for a guy who's a 28 years old.
So this fucking card is just stacked.
This card is stack from top to bottom.
I mean,
you've got 'em cowboy Oliveira versus
Yancey Madeiros is on that fight and David
Tamer is on that fight,
the fight card as well
against drug car clothes.
Now that's a fucking sleeper.
That's the big sleep or fight their cause.
David Tamer is a fucking vicious Stryker,
I mean,
real world class striker
and he's only 28 years old.
And David Tamer really let everybody
know what the fuck is up when he fought
Landover Nada.
A lot of people had no idea who he was,
uh,
up until that fight,
even though he had one,
two fights in a row by Kao in the Octagon.
Um,
when you got to see that kid compete a
against a really talented striker like
land Vanatta and just out strike
him every step of the way,
you really got to see how good he is.
And again,
at 28 years of age,
I don't think we've seen
the best of him yet.
I think he is a,
he has just got a massive,
massive amount of potential and that's
the fight that I think is the big sleep
or fight on this car that
a lot of people are just,
you know,
not quite aware of it.
And the guys fighting Dzhokhar close
eight to know with one draw and very
fucking dangerous fighter as well.
You know,
he's coming from two victories in a row,
uh,
in the UFC and uh,
this will be his,
probably his most dangerous
fight against Tamer.
Tamer is just a wild,
fast dynamic striker with legit
worldclass kickboxing Muay Thai skills.
Very,
very fun card.
So that's going to be next Saturday night.
Also.
Teesha Torres is going to
be fighting the karate.
Heidi,
karate hottie Michelle Waterson.
That should be a fun fight as well.
Teesha Torres,
who's a,
an outstanding striker
and Michelle Waterson who,
uh,
employs a lot of that karate styles,
whether we're talking about that
side where it's sideways stance,
she's got good kickboxing skills as well.
Good submission skills and uh,
Teesha Torres is going to most likely
try to keep this fight on the feet.
There should be a lot of fun.
I mean,
um,
Michelle lost her last fight to rose,
Nama Eunice,
but,
uh,
she'd be Paige vanzant by
submission before that in a a very,
very impressive fight.
Uh,
Angela McGauna,
she'd beat her by submission
before that and Jessica Pinay,
she beat her in Invicta,
uh,
by decision before that.
Uh,
and you know,
she's a,
she's got a lot of hype behind her one
because of she's got a unique style.
She's fighting out of Jackson's,
uh,
in Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
and she's also a very
beautiful young lady.
And of course people like that.
That's a very interesting fight.
Um,
the whole car,
this is like a great
card from top to bottom.
It should be a lot of fun.
But again,
the sleep or fight,
like I said,
is David Tamer.
And your car close.
Keep an eye on tamer.
That mother fucker is wild.
Uh,
all of air versus Felder
should be a lot of fun.
Alvarez versus gauge,
do not go to the bathroom,
do not get popcorn while
that fight is going on.
As long as it lasts,
I fight will be chaos.
Um,
I think so.
Hutto versus pedis is going to be a very
interesting test to see where pedis is
at this stage of his career and to see
if so Hutto can continue to show these
massive jumps and leaps of improvement
that he showed in his last fight against
Wilson Hayes,
the Overeem and Gyno fight.
Fuck.
Amen.
That could be chaos.
I am interested to see whether or not
Francis in Gando can catch Alistair
Overeem or whether or not he finds
himself against a guy who's far too crafty
for him at this stage of his career.
I mean,
we really don't know.
Um,
he fought our Laskey in his last fight,
but with all due respect,
I do not believe that [inaudible]
is in the same category as over him.
I think Overeem represents
another level of danger.
And on top of that over is a very good
ground game that a lot of people are
forgetting about Overeem one,
the Abu Dhabi European trials
he submitted Vito Belfort.
I mean,
Overeem has legitimate
submission skills submitted,
Mark Hunt over in,
can submit guys,
he's got good wrestling skills as well.
You've got to remember he took Stephan
struve to the ground with a beautiful
take down that Teekay owed him
when he got him to the ground.
Um,
he may choose to try to take
Francis and Ghana to the ground.
We might,
we might see that.
We don't know.
Um,
it's just,
it's a very interesting fight to see
where in Ghana is at this stage of his
career and the biggest test of his career
so far and a fight that Overeem was
looking for.
Overeem believes that he has the
skills to put in Ghana in his place and
reestablish himself as the number one
contender in the heavyweight division.
That makes,
uh,
that makes me very
happy to see that fight.
I'm very pumped.
And then of course for all the
marbles in the featherweight division,
Max Holloway versus Josie motherfucking,
although for the title,
you know,
with a guy like all know,
you got to remember you're talking
about a guy who was the best ever at
featherweight for a long fucking time.
You're talking about a god that up until
that Conor McGregor fight had beaten
everybody that they put in front of him.
He rebounded fantastic from that fight
with the Frankie Edgar fight and then got
beat down by Mac Holloway.
I want to see where he's at right now.
I want to see whether or not he can
read browned and I want to see after 29
professional MMA fights
at the highest level,
at 31 years of age,
does he still have what it takes to fight
it a world championship level and can
he come back better than ever.
Now with Max Holloway,
he is.
He's a fucking killer.
Max Holloway has everything
you want to see in a champion,
a championships mindset,
and the way he wanted to go
down at 25 years of age too.
I mean,
just keeps getting better.
He's not even near his prime,
the way he wanted to go down to
Brazil and beat Joe's I Aldo in Rio.
And the way he said it,
that he wanted to fight
him in his country,
then that,
and that's what kings do.
They go to the other person's
kingdom and take their throne.
And that's what he did.
Very exciting fight.
So I'm fucking pumped
for next Saturday night.
Um,
now to answer some of the
criticisms and questions,
a lot of people have been saying,
hey man,
you should probably do this with guests.
I am absolutely going
to do this with guests.
The only reason why I didn't do this
one with a guest is because of my pitch.
I'm on vacation and I felt
like I owed everybody want,
cause this is how it was going to
do one of these things every week.
But the next one I do,
I will bring in a guest
and I'm going to bring in,
I'm going to try and
bring in more fighters.
Um,
I think this is the best way I
think to do a fight or podcasts,
not just,
I mean I'm definitely gonna do more like
where I just sit down and do a regular
podcast with them for the jre podcast.
But when it comes to just
a straight MMA podcast,
I'm going to do quite a few of these,
bring guys and bring some guys in
that are interesting that don't think,
uh,
maybe uh,
um,
maybe some of you folks who've
never heard talk before so that,
that'd be cool.
Um,
I'm also going to ask questions or a,
have you guys ask questions?
So what I'm going to do is,
um,
for the next one I'm going to put a post
up on Instagram and allow you guys and
Gals and non-binary folks to put,
um,
how long do we have to
say that for non binary,
how many of you are out
there that are non-binary?
Is it really important to address you?
Do you feel left out?
If I don't humans,
I'm going to allow all of you
humans to ask questions and we'll,
uh,
pick some good ones and throw those
out there as well in the podcast.
So that's it for now.
Uh,
next week I got,
I got some good guests.
This week I've got some
really fucking funny people.
I have CT Fletcher who's a,
I'm sure he's funny,
but he's also a power lifting legend.
He's going to be here.
Um,
Owen Smith,
the guy that I've been telling you
folks about who's in my opinion,
one of the funniest motherfuckers on the
planet earth and a guy who people are
sleeping on.
People just don't know
how good Owen Smith is.
He'll be here.
Um,
Brian Keaulana will be here this week.
I got a lot of good guests this week,
so that's it for now,
friends.
And,
um,
thank you for tuning into episode
two of the J r e m m a show.
And,
uh,
I'll talk to you guys soon.
Okay.
All right.
Bye.